moi je suis favorable à la suspension
des aides dont on n'a pas la certitude
de la destination vous voyez ce que je
dis vous mais vous le savez vous
aujourd'hui o où va l'argent de ces
aides justement alors les aides d'abord
il faut savoir ce que ça à quoi ça
correspond premièrement l'Union
européenne est le premier soutien
financier sur cette sur ce territoire
deuxème élément c'est de l'ordre ça
c'est élevé puisque c'est selon lesquel
c'est entre 1 milliard 2 et 1 milliard 7
sur la période 2021 2024 et il faut
savoir que sur ce volume la moitié a
d'ors et déjà été versé donc toute
manière il reste en rité 600 millions
que l'on peut suspendre c'est ce à quoi
ça correspond mais ce qui me préoccupe
c'est que nous avons maintenant parce
que c'est avec le recul un certain
nombre d'élément sur l'utilisation de
ces fonds et notamment on a découvert
que sur la période Pr précédente on
avait financé à hauteur de 18 millions
l'université Islam une université
islamique cheak Yassine dans lequel
université on a formé les dirigeants
actuels du ramas donc je dis je suis oui
favorable à une suspension des aides
aide que dont on n'est pas absolument
certain de l'utilisation et de la
destination c'est pas la position de
l'Union européne ça ça impose une union
européne pour l'instant il y a eu faut
le reconnaître il y a eu un cafouillage
à la commission entre un commissaire
hongrois qui s'est exprimé sans doute
plus rapidement mais vous m'interrogez
je suis parlementaire européen je vous
dire moi je seraiis décideur sur ces
sujets voilà ce que je dirais il y a
est-ce que ça on est sûr que ça va à tel
endroit pour soulager aider mais est-ce
que vous regrettez que ça ne soit pas ce
que l'Union européenne dise pour le
moment oui je le regrette oui et si on
ne sait pas on suspend h est-ce que et
d'ailleurs la France comme vous le savez
aide à uteur de 95 millions je pense que
la France devrait adopter aussi cette
position on ne connaît pas l'utilisation
finale on verse pas on connaî
l'utilisation si c'est une solidarité
alimentaire si c'est une solidarité
alors là on peut l'utiliser est-ce que
la France doit aussi réfléchir à à la
remise en cause de ces liens
diplomatiques avec le Qatar qui est
soupçonné de
financerass Al le Qatar comme vous savez
est un grand investisseur oui il
investit dans notre pays un peu plus de
25 milliards
d'euros nous ne sommes pas d'ailleurs
les seul bien bien au contraire puisque
nous avons à peu près la même proportion
d'investissement qatari en Allemagne et
en France donc les deux principales
puissances de l'Union européenne sont à
peu près égalité sur ce planl et nous
nous trouvons et le Qatar investit
d'abord d'abord au Roy umuni donc si on
regarde le continent européen je veux
dire on est pas du tout une
exception deuxème élément le
Qatar peut-il être utile on va le savoir
très vite dans ce conflit parce que le
Qatar vous l'avez observé dans si vous
si vous regardez son attitude au cours
des dernières décennies s'efforce
toujours de jouer un rôle de médiateur
ils essayent d'être médiateurs et euh
sans doute voudront-ils jouer un rôle
dans la libération des otages donc nous
allons savoir je pense dans un délai
rapproché si le Qatar agit agit pour
libérer et aider à la libération mais le
Qatar abrite aussi le chef du Hamas pour
vous il peut jouer le rôle de médiateur
mais c'est ce qu' font depuis si vous
observez le leur histoire vous savez
c'est le le passé éclaire un peu le
présent si vous observez le rôle du
Qatar au cours de ces dernières années
je mets C côté l'aspect économique et
l'aspect financier et tout temp
d'ailleurs pour vous il finance pas le
Hamas le Qatar mais bien sûr que il
finance non donc la question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'ils vont aider ou pas
la libération des otages je vous
rappelle que il y a tous les otages
israélien il y a des 18 français il y a
des Américains et ainsi de suite est-ce
qu'il jouent ce rôle ou pas après il
faudra certainement tirer un certain
nombre de leçon bon paralld on peut
quand même continuer à se comporter de
la même façon avec le pays qui finance
le Hamas
il faudra dès lors que les choses seront
connues seront précisées il faudra
naturellement en tirer un certain nombre
de leç lesquels justement concernant le
rôle du Qatar est-ce qu'il était informé
est-ce que il était associé est-ce qu'il
a financé l'opération ce sont des
questions que l'on doit se poser mais
pas d'ailleurs vous me parlez du Qatar
mais c'est pas simplement vis-à-vis du
Qatar c'est la question vis-à-vis de
l'Iran c'est la question aussi vis-àvis
d' certain pas de relation d'intisement
de relation commcial avec c'est pour ça
que je vous
dis faudra tirer il faudra tirer un
certain nombre de leçons dès lors que
l'on saura la
vérité